hi dr. oz this is Pat and I'm here in
Vermont and I have talked to you once
before and I had started products I was
able to get off on my prescription
medicine I have diabetic taking for
metformin a day and blood pressure
medicine but now what my my problem is
right now I have varicose veins have had
for 35 years and wear support stockings
very heavy duty ones and I'm having pain
in my right leg my left leg does not
swell but my right leg swell there's a
red spot and from there down the leg to
the foot I'm having pain I went to a
surgeon my doctor gave me he put me on
lasix which I do not want to take I am
taking it though because it's helping
with the swelling however my other leg
doesn't swell so anyway this right leg
is swelling and I had the pain I went
through a sir okay and you know I think
akku shout stop you said those things
three times now you repeated yourself
three times okay I got a big line of
people here so what I need from you Pat
is to know your weight 158 and how tall
are you
five six okay five six for lady I'd like
to see you away 145 maybe so you know
maybe 10 pounds overweight not a big
deal but okay you have white hair do you
have to color your hair my hair is gray
okay that's great okay good now you know
why I ask that is the nutrients
necessary to make hair color when
they're missing and they're the same
nutrients that are missing that result
in spider veins varicose veins
hemorrhoids and aneurysms okay they
don't kind of run together because
they're all caused by the same decisions
okay so are you still on medication for
diabetes no I'm not okay good and what
about you what about your high blood
pressure my blood pressure is good
okay so you're taking what the two
healthy start packs are to healthy and
blood sugar pass okay how many heart
attacks okay and you're taking the
sweeties for the diabetes and what are
you taking for high blood pressure I
don't take any well I am taking the
ultimate daily classic okay and I take
selenium okay excellent okay anyway 158
okay now charmagne is that okay now Pat
Tommy she's done a fabulous job here she
no longer has clinical diabetes she's
off all her medication she no longer has
I would put her she's off all her
medication she's doing everything right
with the healthy start pack the sweeties
oldsman daily classic tablets and she is
taking her selenium but she does have
some varicose veins and swelling in one
leg and so what would you add to that to
make I'm you know to deal with these
varicose veins and the swelling in one
leg well she could take the ECM gelcaps
internally okay what else did you
swallow any yeah that's a swelling thing
what would you do or more nutrition did
it help those veins out oh she needs
copper which is selenium well she's
already taken selenium I know so okay
what about ultimate she's already taking
all the daily classic what about the
ultimate cardio sticks and the open
Ultima knives and claws yeah okay
because she may have a blood clot in
that one leg so she has swelling in one
Lake right maybe a blood clot in there
and what is it in the ultimate niacin
plus it would help her if she had a
blood clot zinc nattokinase yeah nano
kinase is an enzyme we also have in the
90s and enzymes a no kinase is in there
too so and what you can do here pet is
to take two or three of those nightly
essence enzymes a bedtime with a half a
glass of water and then take one or two
of the ultimate niacin plus twice a day
say there'll be two bottles a month
yields in the night and get some more
the nano kinase and that's going to help
dissolve blood clots
also you might up your dosage how many
of the selenium your take it
how many quiet so
lenient agree 300k blacks tied up and
tied up into the three twice a day take
two bottles a months and the slams to
get three twice because you're getting
such good results everywhere else and of
course you have to be up all the bands
what do you do sharp to make sure that
she's maximizing your absorption of
these nutrients get her on a gluten-free
diet absolutely you going to need plus
there no fried foods and processed meats
no oils and gluten got to give them all
the inflammatory stuff got to get rid of
the gluten to increase the absorptive
capacity of your intestines and then
call us some to liseberg you're going to
know the things you're improving your
hair color begins to come back and your
varicose veins show signs of getting
better